and uh the on doing you sing the theme
song nicole kidman
i do i do yes only because the director
told me that i had to do it and i'm
a very obedient actor no we've heard
yourself before moulin rouge
you sang in and of course kylie minogue
moulin rouge
i i i yes literally flitted
away momentarily in woolen rouge you
were the absent
yeah yeah i was the road to ruin um
so no i was over the moon to be in a
nicole kidman film from
michael not my film bazza's film but we
were so happy to have you
you know bazz is like aussie royalty as
well so it was you know there was so
much
noise and excitement about moulin rouge
and then yeah i got to have a moment
and weirdly ew mcgregor was on here a
few weeks ago and he was talking about
moulin rouge and he was telling us that
you guys you'd learnt big dance numbers
that we never saw totally i'd learned to
tango
which is a really hard the sequence
really hard and then suddenly
i was not tangling they changed it and
suddenly i was upstairs with the duke
but that was
a lot of the film was workshopped and we
were always changing and
and rewriting and working on it it's
part of baza's process as it gets
formed and we had a massive workshop for
months prior to actually shooting but
yeah so
ewan and i would dance and dance and
dance trying
training together for nothing it's one
it's one of my great memories of
actually dancing with him
and we are going to see you dancing
though uh dancing and singing in the
prom
this is on netflix 11th of december i
saw it on broadway it's such a great
show um and this cast is a dream cast
isn't it
yeah it was one of those things where
meryl and i were doing big little lights
too and we both got
um asked to do the prom together and it
was suddenly to do
to go 180 degrees where you go from
you know the intensity of big little
eyes to to
a musical that is hilarious
and joyful and um
and just but but also a really really
strong story it's a true story
about um a girl who wants to bring her
girlfriend to the prom
and she's not allowed to they they shut
the prom down so it's got this
but it's very funny and it's very
light-hearted and it's and it's filled
with sort of
a great message but also a lot of joy i
mean i'm i'm a supporting role model oh
stop it you're one of the leads
yes you are you own
[Music]
[Laughter]
thank you so much for getting up so
early to see us and looking so gorgeous
nicole kidman george i'm going to be
watching you on saturday night kylie
oh oh beautiful i am i can't wait
uh my heart is a little bitter thank you
i love you love you too from afar
[Applause]
the goalkeeping everybody
you